it
is december 1st so it's time for another
monthly update video this will be the
last one of course
of this tumultuous year of 2020.
the year of the covid pandemic and so
many other things as well
so uh as usual i like to begin by
highlighting three big
things about you know the month to come
or other things you might want to be
attentive to
so big thing number one is that i will
at long
last have the session on the last three
laguna
earth c novels in the worlds of
speculative fiction
this month big thing number two also
having to do with the worlds of
speculative fiction series
there's going to be another vote as
there usually is every year for the
remaining slots
i've already got some decisions made
about who i'm going to be
doing but i'm offering you the chance to
participate
in some brainstorming and then later on
some voting this month
about who should fill the the remaining
slots for
2021 big thing number three we
are continuing in the classic metal
class
with a discussion of the new wave of
british heavy metal i don't think we
tapped that
out so i want to return to that and
discuss some
additional topics and perhaps revisit
some of the topics
we discussed this last month
so what went on in the month of november
2020 well
quite a lot of stuff we began the month
with an incredibly contentious and then
still contested election as we're seeing
the
loser of the the presidential election
still
attempting despite all these setbacks
to engage in lawsuits and try to win by
any means possible so that added a lot
of stress
uh to my students to a lot of other
people and drew a lot of time and
attention
we were also coming off of the big month
of october for
stoicism related stuff i was on deck for
stowacon i helped to organize
stoicon x midwest there was all the
stuff with stoicism today is the editor
of it involved with that we had midterms
for
students and that causes a lot of you
know
engagement and back and forth and stress
for for them and you know all of that
added up to getting a little bit less
done than i had planned
on doing so i didn't do the
worlds of speculative fiction event by
the time
that i'd rescheduled it once i decided i
was just you know i needed the
the break of thanksgiving to just kind
of chill out
i did hold my classic metal class with
my friend scott taruli
and we discussed the new wave of british
heavy metal a topic that we're going to
explore again this coming month
held my ama did my political theory and
practice discussion precisely about the
election results
held my hour hegel hegel q a's and
discussions both the public one and the
private one from my patreon supporters
did my philosophy chat
and you know held the milwaukee stoic
fellowship
as usual so it was it was quite a busy
month and there was a lot of
class building going on i shot um
i don't know how many videos for my
world religions class
my medical ethics class and even some
stuff
for my existentialism class as well
so there was a lot going on behind the
scenes
we managed to produce two wisdom for
life
episodes that airs every every saturday
at 4 pm central
and i also did some guest hosting on the
sunday stoic
podcast one was just me talking about
why reading is fundamental and the other
one was uh
me and my co-host of the wisdom of life
show and co-organizer of the milwaukee
stoic fellowship dan hayes
and we did we did a show that aired this
last sunday so i'll put links for all of
those things
in the video description if you just
click show more you'll see them below
did a bit of academic writing i'm
working on a book chapter
on stoicism and emotional management
and so that's proceeding along quite
well
i shot some videos and this month i'm
happy to say that i was able to produce
half of my previous normal quota of
six half hour hegel commentary videos i
got three of them done
released one of them publicly and the
other two have already been released to
my patreon supporters and you'll see
them coming this this
this month as i release them to the
general public
i also shot some sadler's stories videos
people seem to like those so i'm gonna
keep those coming
and i did some core concept videos uh
three of them on kafka's
in the prison colony a few on marcel
and a few on camus getting through stuff
that i
intended to film in the past but didn't
get to and then a whole series on
simone de bevoir's ethics of ambiguity i
didn't do the whole book
but i did what about nine videos
i think on uh key ideas in the text
we've also got video recordings of the
wisdom for life
show of the classic metal class
this month and i did a review video i've
been meaning to do reviews for a while
i finally got to review of a book that
was sent to me more than two years ago
by hiram crespo his cultivating the
epicurean garden
which is quite a good book in in sort of
philosophy
as a way of life uh sort of sort of
genre so
that's great i did a lot of releasing
podcast episodes and producing those
quite a few on jon stewart mills
utilitarianism
um some video or some rather some
podcast episodes on hegel's
self-consciousness section
leading up through the master slave
dialectic a few on on marcel's on the
ontological mystery
three on david hume's treaties on human
nature including the
famous passage about reason being the
slave of the passions
a number of them on de bevoir's second
sex which i'll also be
continuing to release this coming month
and even
a one-off on robert nozick's experience
machine
so you know got quite a few things done
in november towards the end of the month
we decided that we would just like take
the last
week as break in part because
um academically none of the places that
i'm teaching actually had a fall break
and man the students were burnt out by
by thanksgiving week and so was i
so some well needed relaxation
and enjoyment and some down time and
that's how we finished out the month
so the hope is through december to
finish out the year
strong i've got a number of events lined
up for you all of which are online
all of the times that i'm giving of
course are central time because i'm
based here in milwaukee so you'll have
to
adjust to your own local time zone
on the 5th that's this saturday coming
up at noon
i'll be holding my ama that's ask me
anything session
using youtube live you can come in and
i'll answer whatever questions you've
got
on the 6th the day after that also at
noon
i will have my political theory
and practice discussion haven't yet
decided on
a topic so that will be announced fairly
soon
again you can click see more and you'll
see the links to those below so you can
set up a
reminder for yourself if you want to on
the 12th
at noon we'll be having our classic
metal class so
scott truly will be joining me and we'll
be
continuing to discuss some key topics in
the new wave of british heavy metal
which is not a genre as such but rather
you could think of it as an incredibly
fertile time within the development
of heavy metal and it spun
off several different genres or gave
additional impetus
to additional genres as well
and then that same day for patreon
supporters
i will be having my philosophy chat
i'll be opening that up to all of my
patreon
supporters on the main patreon page
usually it's just for
10 and up patreon supporters but
you know it's going to be christmas
coming up so i'm going to do a little
bit of
gift giving that way that's a video
conferencing it's a little bit more
intimate than the ama session
since people can you know see me and we
can talk in real time
on the 16th at 5 00 p.m we'll be having
our
public hegel q a just
and discussion session you don't have to
be a patreon supporter it's public it's
open to anybody who wants to talk about
hegel
or philosophy more broadly on the 19th
we will at last be having our session
devoted to ursula k
le guin's three uh
earth-sea novels collections of short
stories that came after the trilogy
really expanding that narrative universe
and displaying the you know brilliance
of of herself
we're going to be joined by a special
guest
a scholar who has published some stuff
on the green
for the video conferencing session the
way that works is we have
my video which runs for about an hour
and a half right
and you can do live chat with me as
you're watching the video as it
premieres
and then we have a video conferencing
session where we go deeper into the
the topic so i'll be joined by by a
colleague of mine
and then nothing going on
until the end of the month on the 26th
at uh 12 p.m i'm going to try to produce
another one of those self-directed study
videos i think it's probably going to be
on boethius because i'm going to be
shooting some video stuff on boethius so
may as well connect up with
that and then finally on the 31st that's
new year's eve at 6
p.m we will have the milwaukee stoic
fellowship we'll be discussing some
additional chapters
of antonio macaro's excellent book
more than happiness which is a
comparative study of
stoicism and buddhism i should remind
you that
every saturday at 4 pm
central time on river west radio which
streams
across the internet as well as here in
the local milwaukee area
we have the wisdom for life show some of
them are
repeats of old shows because dan and i
are only recording every two weeks
but we have some new live stuff coming
up
including coming up this this current
weekend
we're going to be discussing the paradox
of choice
so that's that's all the event stuff
coming up
this is a month where i have to do a ton
of grading i've got
six classes so that's six classes of
students
handing in their work which then needs
to be graded and i need to turn in final
grades
so there's a lot of work on that and i'm
also working
diligently at this book chapter and at a
trying to get back to a collaborative
project that i'm doing with a colleague
and friend of mine
from the university of oslo on
pro-iracis as causality
in in stoic and aristotelian texts that
may sound a little abstract to you but
trust me it's some some really
interesting and cool stuff
uh video work i'm i've got a few more
videos on camus
core concept videos to shoot and then
i'm going to be
dipping into fanon for for a while
as i finish up my existentialism class
i'm going to be doing
black skin white masks obviously i won't
be doing the entire book
in core concepts but a good portion
of the key ideas from it and then i'm
going to be shooting some core concept
videos
for one of my classes coming up in in
spring
i'll be shooting some stuff on
boethius's consolation of philosophy
i'll also be producing the half hour
hegel
videos i'm hoping to get six done this
month and get back on track
finish out this morality section get
into the
religion section by the beginning of the
year
of the phenomenology obviously got some
reviews videos to do
i'll be doing some more saddler stories
videos as well
and i've got some q a videos that i want
to do answers to common questions
on stoicism on some key questions that
keep coming up so i'll do that
there'll be videos of all the events of
course and
the leguin video will be premiering
on the 19th so you might want to
you know stay tuned for that as well
um podcast work that i'm going to be
doing
so i'm actually going to be doing a a
vote
that my patreon supporters will get to
have extra
votes in but i'm going to do it publicly
as well
so you know i've got a few more de
bevoir video
podcast episodes to release and then
what i'm thinking about
as far as the order goes is you know i
want to do some
cicero some aristotle some heidegger
some dostoyevsky
based on the the lecture videos that
i've done i take those and then i
turn them into podcast episodes so i'm
going to put out a vote pretty soon
for people to decide which of those
i should do first and then we'll take
you know the second most popular and
that'll be the
second one these are all figures that
i've done some saddlers lectures
podcast episodes on before so it's not
a new author but you know what do you
want more of that's the
general idea there and then of course
you know we've got the holidays coming
up i don't foresee being able to get
together
with families you know particularly with
my kids unfortunately but we'll
we'll do some video conferencing
and we'll just kind of take it easy
kovit is out of control here
in in wisconsin and in the midwest in
general
and so we've got to be really careful
about that but i think we should be able
to have a good
holiday season nonetheless and
have some good down time the other thing
i'm going to be doing
over this month is starting to build up
my classes for spring
i've already got my spring semester more
or less
set up i should be teaching five classes
all of which will be online and many of
which are classes
actually all of which are classes i've
taught before so i already have material
and structure but i always like to build
out some new things
as well and you might see some of those
things coming up with videos
thinking about a sequence of videos that
will probably air
in january providing advice to students
about
things like how you know i'm going to
redo the how to read a philosophical
text
or what is plagiarism and why should we
avoid it you know things
things along those lines so that's
that's coming up i don't know if that'll
be coming out in december
or if that stuff will be coming out in
january but you could stay tuned for
that
i hope all of you have a great month and
stay
safe stay healthy and you know keep
reading
you